I don't sleep at night because the
prompter is too loud so I sleep in the
morning and sometimes I cover my ears
with by the pillow so I can sneak this
body before the war in Gaza fair ibaka
shared the same teenaged preoccupations
as many other 16 year old girls clothes
shopping and music but then she began
tweeting about the conflict and all that
changed actually this is my third word
to witness so this is not my first time
to hear it sounds like that but this is
my first word to fail to feel unsafe
because in the previous two words I was
sure that I won't be bombed because I'm
an innocent civilian but in this world
you know they bombed randomly civilians
houses so I feel that can be won at any
moment in the months since the fighting
began fires following his sword from
fewer than a thousand to pushing a
hundred and fifty thousand she tweets at
night when the Israeli air strikes are
at their height I don't plan for my
future because any work and such any
time and kill me so I just think of my
of the present time and I think if there
was no Israel I would have visited my
friends and when I was back in Jerusalem
and Hebron but now I can do nothing I
dream of visiting the other places in
Palestine but I can't
fires tweeting is cool worldwide media
attention it's unfiltered and pulls no
punches actually I see that this is the
only way I can hope Gaza and I I mean
that I don't have the I don't have
enough power to go and carry a weapon
and and kill Israelis soldiers people
might be surprised that somebody like
you even wants or thinks about the
possibility of taking up arms and
killing people
I don't want killed civilian a civilian
I just want if I had enough power I
would kill people who kill us but I
don't I don't love a blood if the
Israeli government the Israeli Prime
Minister was to see this what would you
like to say to him I would tell them
that they they should stop this floor
and break the siege that kills us Oh
since I was born I have been suffering
and because
of siege I want them to break the siege
and end this war peacefully Farrah's
father works as a neurosurgeon across
the road from their house at the Shifa
hospital where dozens of Palestinians
injured by the shelling have been
treated
she says he tries to hide the images of
the dead and wounded from her but she
looks at them anyway and then tweets her
thoughts their abode in sky news in Gaza